Good evening
Zdravstvuyte (hello).
Welcome to gaming week. Gaming week continue and so does papers, please
Is my son still alive?
Probably not. ( subtitle by *I am HeRe *in description at bottom )
"Dancers at Grestin Club found dead."
This is so sad. I am shaking and crying.
I probably had something to do with this
Glorious day.
Inspector,
Search scanner, very good.
Yes, Kolechians must be  approved
Okay glory to Arstotzka. Next.
Privet (hello)
You're visiting friends.
How long, a couple of weeks?
Kolechia, stupid Kolechia. I spit on Kolechia.
This is so crazy. You will not believe this.
You have been selected [for] random search.
It's never happened before, I swear. No discrimination, dumb bitch.
Alysia Stinson, what a stupid name what a stupid face. Vedor. I've been Vedor. It's disgusting.
Disgusting lady, get out of my sight. Okay.
Kolechia. Vedor. Khorosho (good).
Khorosho (good). Passport number okay a visit she say visit right?
Missing in the
Alysia, Alysia, Alysia Stinson Kolechia...
Stinson passport khorosho (good).
Visit enter. Bye. Okay, okay.
Okay
Dosvidanya (bye)
Next cause no trouble check out new fountain new fountain. Very pretty
Papers. Zdravstvuyte (hello)
Transit.
How long you stay?
Couple weeks.
Transit khorosho (good). Okay first we check if passport is okay.
Okay.
What was I doing?
Okay this passport stupid.
Passport Impor what is this? Are you poor?
StUuPid!
Tsunkeido. Khorosho (good). Female!
Nani desu ka (what)? okay khorosho (good) *laughs*
What's your name Borla Grizhenko.
You were born in Tsunkeido. It was correct, right?
Tsunkeido and you expire what about the serial number? Khorosho (okay)
Enter by... I mean, I don't see a problem
They kind of look different there on the picture. Don't they? Let's check that. Oh it is why you look old I
Don't know what to say. It's me. Don't waste my time. What do you have here, Borla?
Applicant ring appraised
Border like Gary's ankle. So this is it is correct. She just had a really ugly photo
You look like a potato
left in the Sun
for a century
But you may enter. Khorosho (okay) cause no trouble checkout fountain! check out new fountain what
WhHaAtT?!
non matching photo
Fingerprints do not make oh they have to match the record. I didn't know that god, dammit
They don't tell me! The higher-ups. Don't tell me and then they don't pay me when I make problem. Why you bald?
Danil super
Ok
You need a lot of things, huh?
Supar, Danil
male
First we check passport. Where is this? Oh bristan, Aubristan.
Passport, ok fine arts stupid job. Why you no work for government?
Danil Supar, khorosho (okay)
Untill how long one month
and this last one one month okay, and you expire I mean, I don't see problem, but there's always problem Oh
Aubristan, okay khorosho dosvidaniya (okay bye).
Oh, we forgot. Oh, shoot shit. They're gonna fire me work??
Did you say work? Okay Oh God. Can I have your passport back? I need to check one thing God.
Please check out fountain! :D
Check out fountain, next!
Fuck me invalid name. Hey now I'm gonna get fired check out fountain
Papers, please Ryan, but Ryan you do not look like man.
Hey what you look like old lady
Are you women? What is this question? I this is no discrimination
What is this photo for destro
Is it a district far Edisto? You are men Wow are we were?
incredible
Maybe get new haircut. Okay. You are 172. Ok. You are 7 to kill
Ok, you are born in date? Ok, Oh
Same as me, very epic. No way. It's not
Orvech Vonor is correct
everything is correct, Surgenor, Ryan
Ryan
Ok
Check out fountain
Next I cannot get another ticket. Otherwise, my son will literally die
Papers, please. Ahx Kolechia!
disgusting
14 days, I will find something to kill. I mean to send you away. Vedor. I know Vedor, stupid city stupid people
Kolechia,  filthy Koleciha. Ok, your say your name is justina
You say your name is Crag, but here it says Crog
Why it's a Crog
Why it says Crog
It says crag
Why does it say matching that one is clearly not matching??? that I did the video game did an oopsie?
Matching am I crazy? Oh, it isn't
I'm crazy. I'm sorry. It looks very similar. Okay the number okay
Expire date is okay birthday fine. You said transit 14 days.
Want to get you somehow
Fine hopefully I don't make mistake. Oh my god, I have to search her
Come back
Come back and forgot
God, dammit, my son
It's going to be so disappointed
Are you kidding me this never happened this never ever happened? I
Can't believe I forgot to search her.
AaaAAAaaAAAaAAAHh!
You will select a random search now I have to look at the ugly lady instead of pretty lady
Damn, I hate my job. I mean, I love my job. Glory to Artitozka?
Disgusting filthy Kolechia
What is your work permit
Xavia, Sivirity, Xavia, Sivirity, Yurko City!
Worst place I've ever been I got chlamydia in Yurko
It's not good woman not good. I mean, I don't see a problem but there's always a problem
next
Check out fountain
No problem, dosvidaniya (bye)
Basic this is crazy
This is not happening and it's first time I work here but it's saying random search
Incredible stupid Shad-oy, Safadi Safadi
Shaddy, what stupid name what stupid --what does this?
What is this
No weapons or contraband why you carry this there's zero tolerance you can see that
Slow down my friend. I have only harmless medicine I give you ten credits to let me through
You cannot bribe an officer of Arstotzka!
They pay me. They must pay you well for such opinions. They don't pay me at all
next
Entry not guaranteed. Oh my god. What happened to you lady?
You're visiting friends. How long?
three months
Okay
Now we check passport
You are from Antegria. Is that correct?
Yes da (yes)
St. Marmero
Ah, St. Marmero
It's very nice in summer
What is your password is correct and you are born very old lady wow
You're very old
You're so awful
How are you so old
Why are you so old?
Karina lab no lab knows
the
Visit enter by okay
Not enter by this expire
Old lady go back to old lady country. I don't care you busy
reject denied
by bike
You will not enjoy fountain you will not enjoy the family entry. Not guaranteed my god, you're ugly
You are Antegria Glorian, horosho(ok)
Everly oh my god. You are ugly lady
Emigrate forever in our glorious City. Why why we do this? Oh
Look at this, dude
Check it again detained
detain
Send it off to Gulag. You will not enjoy the fountain entry not guaranteed. Oh
What a glorious day my son is sick, okay
Today my son
Today, I'm very happy
Will get the medicine
Wait, I can upgrade booth. I will upgrade booth instead. I can't do a anything anyways, Oh
Iris Tosca has zero tolerance for delinquency. What is this? Your family will be sent back to the village
You are under arrest until your debts are repaid
No, no glory to Arstotzka yeah. Noo,nyet(no)
Have failed are you kidding me? Okay, we are back
Glorious day
Nothing happened
Okay new rules the collection have filed complaint open
Stupid collector a
diplomat will arrive today for high-level discussion automatic searches of
Kolechian citizens no longer authorized
Nyet!(no)
Filthy crybabies diplomats require only a passport and very diplomatic
authorization
refer to rulebook
Next
Dobri we hear papers
Diplomatic our well, where is your diplomatic of the rice? Oh, you have it? Okay fine
Lefravski stupid name. Josef  stupid name!
your code city
Worse city my cat got aids in your code city. Ah
Yurko sucks
Okay, what is your passport number nine to be OW
3 9 4 6 H and you expire by fine your Co how long you stay in our city?
How long you want to be in here fine? Check out fountain?
next
Next
Papers I don't have all day. I have to upgrade booth
My presence was ok. What is this diplomatic authorizations?
Diplomats are you diplomats? Oh
Sure, ok
You're from Obristan!
Ok, it's not Artotzka, but it's not bad
My god, you look ugly on photo. Is this correct?
While you look so ugly
Many years have been cruel. Let's check fingerprints. Give me this
Name Dijana Gromova. Is this correct?
Okay, it's correct you give this back do I give this back
Maya!
My dog is barking. It's very stressful do this job. Okay number Dijana Gromova.
diplomatic authorization
Fine. I don't understand. I don't understand. What other
Diplomats require authorization da but you are not from Impor. Oh
It means you can enter these places. Ah, I understand of course, of course, of course
Very well you can enter
NExt! Check out fountain!
Non matching photo finger prints do not match record. What are you talking about? Oh my god, is this guy?
Are you happy to see I have everything you asked for now. Oh
Wow, it looks so real. What is this? Hey
Can I ask matching day oh wait
Has it expired
What do I get him for
He needs an entry permit
We don't take ticket hey no guys help me take it say it's good you check again maybe
I'm sorry, you need every ticket come back again. Ha ha
You nice guy, but I have business in our thoughts. Can I get write papers and come see you? Ok, very well next
Papers place with this purpose you plan to work. Ok one year.
You enter by.
1212 horosho.
Mika arrange
Mika arrange you look very ugly. What what is this? You tell me? Listen? I do not discriminate
But why you look like one man?
Why do you ask for no reason random search Oh
Collect yeah, I
Almost didn't search you
But why
What I Spit on collection why you wearing man clothes
There is a problem with your documentation
detains
gulag
NEXT!
You will not enjoy fountain!
Yes
Glory to arstotzka what money
Order awaits what no need this car. Oh
It's big
NEXT!
Glorious day to you
Kaliesha why you come here, this is crazy
Wait, she needs a diplomat, right?
I'm no longer allowed to search them
Damn it, Oh west Crescent terrible place. I lost my left testicle in West Crest
Okay, you want to immigrate ah why you came to live with my husband stupid their van?
Josephine their van Josephine
CP all
Passport is okay to me and number you look very old
Forever enter by
1122 I don't see problem, but I also don't want to accept you
Is there anything what would it be just VIN better one?
Why this expired I could not come until now but that is not my problem
Will the collection go back home!!!
You will not enjoy fountain
Papers?
AaAAAaaaaHhH!
Arstotzka welcomes you back
Octave Alice district. This is very good district. My father became immortal in this district
Octo Valley is very nice
It's very nice area. I'm told you are 162. This is standard procedure
I am so sorry for taking time your precious time
glorious arstotzka Lee
always very similar more acts obscure more rock
Hacha issued in parodies, 'no. Oh
You got from different district
That's okay apparently
1982 11 13
11 13. Oh
No. Oh no. Oh
No
Your document is expired
It's a mistake. I just renew it. Okay, Cara show
There is new fountain so come back soon. Okay?
Next
Entry not guaranteed next
Papers, what is this?
visiting friends ah?
How long is they?
90 days that is correct Pyotr Milenko.
pewter
malenko
It's been three months Santa Maria mo. It's actually not bad aunt agrea
Santomero you look a little tired Esther a problem
Visit three months he say visit but why this is work permit or is entry permit
Am I crazy
Basic rules
workers must have worked past I
Am crazy oh
He is not working that's why it was it looked like the word pass I'm stupid
Okay, I think he's fine
Fine go then I don't care enjoy. Look at fountain
enjoy fountain
Come on yes
Enjoy fountain papers Oh iris Tuscan
Welcome back home Drake's Carmen. I hope you had good stay
You don't have to be in dirty City anymore your mail car? Oh sure
I grew my first nipple in parodies. Nah, it's very good players parodies. No
More like parodies nuts am I right?
Okay. Sorry not funny. I make joke pass time quicker
You know, my son is sick. Not your plug problem. Of course
What am I doing, I'm just making sure
Everything is okay
What is
I'll be reset Vasily low. I think he's okay you okay?
Dad
Have you seen new fountain if not, you should look
My son is very sick. Your son will die without medicine. This is so sad
Another glorious day, okay
Let's do one more top level collector and expose that iris not conspire what not me
This is crazy December 1st glorious day
What is this a pig
Inspector an undercover agent of the Ministry of an information has been compromised what?
Expect a possible drop of letter
next
Yeah, what who are you?
Hello
Are you the spy?
What no
Never I am guard here. My name is Collins
They told me I get good position then send me here. This is thanks I get
Now they pay me almost nothing. They pay us all as much don't complain. Yes, but look I
Get small bonus when you detain people
More detain more they give me for processing but this is not fair. You should get something too. So I fix problem. I
Give you 5 credits for every two people you take sounds good deal. I give money to you after I get paid
Like let us make best of this
Okay, it's the same time
Next
Okay, who are you Oh
What is purpose pass-through duration
Two days
Okay. So your name you say is Thomas?
carpenter
Carpenter you from East Creston
It's not bad place. It's not good place. There is no East grayskin an import
What is this the issuance it is not correct. I don't know anything about that b-day
Get out send him to gulag you will not enjoy fountain you will never enjoy a fountain again
If people don't appreciate the good panting
Okay, you are transit
What is your name two days, this is correct
What are you from? República? Excuse me? Let me check a república
laser
Indeed ask that is correct. And the passport looks correct to my fellow friends is very cute
Okay cause pass
Vegas-y your name has began in it. Why why this is your name?
Don't understand ok horosho trend enter by 1213 that is correct car show
Okay, thus we done yeah look at no fountain
Papers please!
Have not much time. You must hold on to these. What is this? Keep them safe today? I am being followed by ambassador
They pretend to be from ministry information, but it is lie if they ask for documents give them these instead
Do not get too mixed up gosh. Oh
So wait, which one I give this one. Okay, Farah show me ax papers, please. I am NOT your delivery service
Do not leave me documents
Visiting friends how long you stay?
couple months
Marry gatherers, what is this place?
Never heard of merge areas. This is real. Are you lying to me? You better not lie. I have eagle eyes
There it never be I never make mistake
Law, Mary Gary is real. It's crazy. Never visit
Harmon Sebastian what stupid name add man? What is your passport Dean? Okay
Okay, it's correct
Enter by twelve nineteen is correct your mail your mare garius
You are really old and really ugly and I don't like your face
this expires
By the time can you do that?
Well, you should get new passport you dummy I think it's fine check out fountain yes
Come on I don't have time next
What's purpose visiting how long
Okay
Penobscot Emily
Emily van nose cap
You are very very not pretty help me
Okay, the number is correct and this expires when
Next year, that is correct
Lorna's is that inab straighten? I forgot
Oops trillion you dummy?
Lord mass this stupid place. I don't like it enter by 12 27. This is all correct. Enjoy a new fountain
Yes, I want to detain people I need money
Papers come on papers papers. I
Am from the ministry and information you have something to give us are you giving me money?
All right, so I'm supposed to give you this
but I give you I
Don't know I guess I give this
Yes
You know, I guess I can't give them both. I have money I eat tonight I upgrade booth
For this purpose visiting friends. All right, where's your stupid passport?
Where your passport give it to me dumb snake sorry, you don't have it. Oh you have it? Okay fine
So she say she visit for a few weeks one month and you have to enter by
today, you know you're fine and
This expires is fine. You rate ok
Passport number is it correct?
The female the skull from skull is actually not that bad place
They have sea fish in skull because they made of skull the donor the donor
Ian look
girl look
horosho
You look you look a little crazy. I got to say it is correct. She busy
It's all correct, but I need to detain
Fine. Enjoy fountain
Yes
Come on oh my god there. I need to detain someone Oh my fellow artist Otakon
Welcome back. How was your trip? Terrible? I'm sure it's awful out there Durex Carmen now dregs
I am so sorry. Are you do look like female action? Never mind. You're from East cresting
Is getting the greatest place in our structure. We have fountain in Heath
I'm sure you've seen many times this fountain and this was issued in
Alton, ah, that is correct
Everything looks great. You are 40 near 60
Okay
When this expires
Enjoy the family wait, my name is Carmen GRU. You have something of mine
Please no, I don't
What is this
read quickly aerosol skies great country poisoned by corrupt leaders
Which has made the help free arrest Otsuka the order of Erick, okay
I read do not lose this. What is this?
What is this? Oh
It's my time
Day nine your son has died. I am absolutely devastated. My son is dead
It's in the chat. Okay, boys that was end of episode. Hope you enjoy
Goodbye.
WhAt?! You never played Tuber Simulator!
You know, it's fun right? I'm not supposed to give my opinion....
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not. Not convinced yet? Okay. I'll cut you a deal!
The game is available for free and that's a great price!!!